SANDEEP DINESH: When it
comes to distributed systems,
handling failure is key.
Kubernetes helps with this
by utilizing controllers
that can watch the
state of your system
and then restart services
that stop performing.
But on the other
hand, Kubernetes
can actually forcibly
terminate your applications
to ensure the overall
health of the system.
In this episode of
Kubernetes Best Practices,
let's take a look at how
you can help Kubernetes
do its job more efficiently
and reduce the downtime
your apps experience.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the pre-container
world, most applications
were running on VMs
or physical machines.
If an application crashed,
it could take quite a while
to boot up a replacement
to take its place.
Or even worse, someone would
need to log into the machine
and fix the issue by hand--
even in the middle of the night.
If you only had
one or two machines
to run the application,
this time to recovery
was unacceptable.
So instead, it became common
to use process-level monitoring
to restart applications
when they would crash.
If the application crashed,
the monitoring process
could capture the
exit code and then
restart the server instantly.
With the advent of systems like
Kubernetes, this kind of system
was just built into the
infrastructure itself.
Kubernetes uses an
invent loop to make sure
that resources are
healthy from containers
to the nodes themselves.
This means you no longer need
to manually run these monitoring
processes.
If a resource has
failed a health check,
Kubernetes will just
automatically spin up
a replacement.
But Kubernetes does a lot more
than monitor your application
for crashes.
It can create more copies
of your application
to run on multiple machines.
It can update your application.
It can even run multiple
versions of your application
at the same time.
So this means that there
are many reasons why
Kubernetes might terminate a
perfectly healthy container.
Like if you update
your deployment
with a rolling
update, Kubernetes
will slowly terminate old pods,
while spinning up new ones.
If you drain a node, Kubernetes
will terminate all pods
in that node.
And if a node runs
out of resources,
Kubernetes will terminate
pods to free those resources.
So it's important
that your application
can handle termination
gracefully so
that if there is a minimal
impact on the end user
and there's a minimal impact
on the time to recovery.
So this means that it should
save all the data that
needs to be saved, close
down any network connections,
finish any work that's left--
other similar tasks.
So in practice, this means
your application needs
to handle the sigterm message.
When it receives this message,
it should begin to shut down.
Once Kubernetes decided
to terminate your pod,
a series of events takes place.
Let's look at each one of
these steps in the Kubernetes
termination lifecycle.
So let's say we want to
terminate one of these pods.
At this point, the pod will
stop getting new traffic.
Containers running in the
pod will not be affected,
but all new traffic will be
prevented from coming in.
So now let's look
at the prestop hook.
The prestop hook is a
special command or HTTP
request that is sent to
the containers in the pod.
If your application
doesn't gracefully
shut down when
receiving a sigterm,
you can use this hook to
trigger a graceful shutdown.
So most programs gracefully shut
down when receiving a sigterm.
But if you're using a
third-party code or some system
that you don't really
have control over,
the prestop hook is a great way
to trigger a graceful shutdown,
without modifying
the application.
So now, at this
point, Kubernetes
will send the sigterm signal
to the containers in the pod.
This signal lets the
containers know that they're
going to be shut down soon.
So your code should
listen for this event
and then start shutting
down cleanly at this point.
So this may include stopping
any long-lived connections,
like a database connection
or a WebSocket stream,
saving the current state,
and doing things like that.
So even if you're
using the prestop hook,
it's important
that you test what
happens to your application when
you send it the sigterm signal
so you're not surprised when
it happens in production.
At this point,
Kubernetes will wait
for a specified time called
the termination grace period.
By default, this is 30 seconds.
It's important to
note that this happens
in parallel to the prestop
hook and the sigterm signal.
Kubernetes will not wait for
the prestop hook or the sigterm
signal to finish.
If your app finishes shutting
down before the termination
grace period is done, Kubernetes
will just move to the next step
immediately.
Now if your pod takes longer
than 30 seconds to shut down,
make sure you increase
the grace period.
You can do that by setting
the termination grace period
seconds option in the pod YAML.
For example, this example
has it set at 60 seconds.
And now, the last step--
if the containers are still
running after the grace period,
they are sent the sigkill signal
and then forcibly removed.
At this point, Kubernetes cleans
up all the objects as well.
Kubernetes terminates
pods for many reasons
and making sure that
your application handles
these terminations
gracefully is core
to creating a stable surface.
I'll see you on the next episode
of Kubernetes Best Practices.
[MUSIC PLAYING]